jean luc mélenchon le fondateur de la
france a soumises qui mobilisait ses
partisans hier avec la marche pour la
6ème république jérôme à rabieh et
quentin calmet il était
porté par des sondages qui progresse
jean luc mélenchon voulait faire de
cette marche pour la 6ème république une
démonstration de force politique avec
plus de cent mille personnes revendiqués
par l'équipe de campagne l'ambiance
était au beau fixe et l'espoir présent
chez les militants 1 je vois tous ces
gens de tous les âges avec un
enthousiasme évident franchement ça fait
chaud au coeur c'est vraiment une elodie
dame campanois chasser l'autre campagne
elle est vraiment en puissance encore
plus sourire de rigueur aussi pour la
guerre de rapprocher du candidat qui n'a
désormais qu'un but accéder au second
tour mais ce qui compte dans les
sondages elle est dynamique et nous on
est en dynamique donc maintenant je sais
pas trop ce
qui peut permettre qu'on ait perdu mon
tour entre macro et l'extrême droite
c'est le but argent les cochons pour
bouleverser les pronostics jean luc
mélenchon a déroulé son programme social
manière de s'installer comme la seule
alternative au duel macron le pen
annoncé et le candidat en appel aux
abstentionnistes aux indécis et aux
autres forces de gauche en choisissant
l'union populaire
dès le premier tour
vous faites un choix de société
car tel est bien dorénavant le sort de
cette élection puisque monsieur
maquereau a annoncé fort et clair son
programme alors oui ce vote est un
référendum sociale vous êtes prévenus il
y a cinq ans la grande marche parisienne
avait été un déclic dans la campagne de
jean-luc mélenchon qui avait ensuite
rattrapée puis doublée son adversaire
socialiste benoît hamon sans toutefois
réussir à accéder au second tour à un
plafond de verre que le candidat espère
cette fois faire voler en éclats
jusqu'où montera jean luc mélenchon on
en débat tout de suite avec claire
châtié chartier bonsoir vous êtes
journaliste et essayiste stewart show
bonsoir directeur des études politiques
chez viavoice ou publié l opinion des
émotions c'est au co édité par les
éditions de l'aube et la fondation jean
jaurès jean garrigues bonsoir historien
président du comité d'histoire
parlementaire et politique votre livre
la tentation du sauveur est publié aux
éditions payot on est également en
duplex en visioconférence avec leslie
mann le président et co-fondateur doxa
bonsoir yaël bienvenue a aussi et
matthieu croissandeau éditorialiste
politique à mes côtés comme tous les
lundis comme tous les mercredis bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi on va donc
analyser ensemble cette dynamique jean
luc mélenchon en regardant tient ce
dernier sondage ipsos pour france info
et le parisien avec les intentions de
vote au premier tour on à emmanuel
macron à trente et une nuits marine le
pen 17 jean luc mélenchon le voici à 13
devant eric zemmour et valérie pécresse
à 10% alors on a regardé parce que sont
les dynamiques évidemment qui nous
intéresse claire chartier il ya trois
mois il était enfant et 5 points quand
vous l'analysez la tendance
alors effectivement la référence à la
campagne précédente s'impose est ce que
cette fois la tortue mélenchon est
arrivé à va toucher au but il ay avait
empli lui-même cette image à tortue je
pense que c'est c'est quand même ça
paraît quand même très difficile parce
que 2017 c'était il ya presque un siècle
il ya 50 qui se sont passées et on n'est
pas du tout dans la même configuration
c'était quand même la nouveauté
mélenchon s'étaient donc là surtout son
ascension avait surpris tout le monde
cinq ans se sont passés il n'a pas
tellement
finalement concrétisé en tout cas
rentabiliser cette ce très beau score de
la campagne fin de l'élection il en a
pas fait grand chose et surtout entre
temps il a quand même
beaucoup cassé du sucre sur le dos de
ses camarades de gauche aujourd'hui pour
arriver quand même à vraiment à se
qualifier pour le second tour il va
falloir qu'ils élargissent ce sont sa
base donc ça semble extrêmement
difficile
et puis en plus il a hésité sur le plan
tactique entre la tactique de
l'insoumission qui connaît bien
d'ailleurs à son à son propos de projets
et puis la tactique rassembleur de
gauche donc en fait il y avait sans
arrêt une valse-hésitation là dessus
donc ça me semble assez mal je dirais
que c'est quand même une hypothèse assez
peu probable je ne sais pas ce qu'en
pensent les autres camarades du plateau
qu'il arrive à élargir et puis il ya
tous et on en parlera certainement après
finalement pour élargir sa base d
abstention et là il va se retrouver en
frontal avec marine le pen selon nick
ans à quoi évidemment un chapitre 2 de
ces débats la question des
abstentionnistes hiwar chola la marche
d'hier quand même nouvelle démonstration
de force alors si on la compare à celle
d'il ya cinq ans qu'il y avait un petit
peu moins de monde hier mais mais mais
quand même on voit aussi un jean luc
mélenchon qui est peut-être un peu je
sais pas si c'est routinier uku
superstitieux lancé arrière mais répète
les les
les axes de sa campagne président louis
oui sans doute arriver dans une
dynamique c'est évident sur les
différentes intentions de vote il faut
voir quand même aussi les chiffres
derrière ses intentions de vote il a un
sens que l'électorat qui est important
mais qui reste relatif par rapport à ses
concurrents 48 % des électeurs mêlant
chant 2017 sont prêts à revoter
mélenchon en 2022 s'est élevé mais c'est
peu par rapport à maquereau est à 72
pour cent cinquante six pour le pen deux
autres écueils à mon sens est
actuellement vous avez raison de le
rappeler à gauche puisque vous avez
quand même 12 % des électeurs mélenchon
2017 qui serait prêt cette fois ci à
voter roussel 11% pour jeannot donc si
on fait le cumul ça fait quand même un
score qui est non négligeable sachant
que le la qualification pour le 3e voire
le second tour va peut-être se jouer à
pas grand-chose et enfin troisièmement
c'est les abstentionnistes est vrai que
en 2007 il faut se rappeler que
jean luc mélenchon fait des scores quand
même assez élevé sur les catégories
population qui traditionnellement votre
peu c'est à dire qu'il fait premier chez
les primo votants 18 24 ans il est à 30%
il fait 31 % c'est les demandeurs
d'emploi effet 24 pour chance et les
ouvriers effectivement vous avez raison
de rappeler l'abstention sera un clé une
clé majeure pour oui ou non concrétisée
cette dynamique jean garrigues est ce
qui peut endosser le costume du sauveur
dont vous parlez dans votre vivre
pas du tout
c'est pas une tradition forcément dans
sa famille politique a alors parce que
c'est aux antipodes de la tradition de
gauche est toujours un refus de cette de
cette figure même si de manière
objective certains à gauche comme léon
gambetta au tout début la troisième
république clemenceau ou même pierre
mendès france dans les années 50 ont pu
faire figure de sauveur mais il ya une
méfiance de la part des électeurs et de
la part des représentants eux mêmes de
la gauche comme jean luc mélenchon je
pense qu'il est testerait qu'on assimile
à cette figure d'homme providentiel
ce qui est vrai c'est que dans le
contexte de cette campagne d' une gauche
totalement émietté et amoindrit il
apparaît effectivement comme une sorte
de figure qui peut au moins atténuer un
peu le le désastre à gauche kiki de
cette manière là peut faire figure de
nos sauveurs d'homme providentiel pour
la gauche c'est un petit peu d'ailleurs
l'image de celui qui est une de ces
grandes références quai françois
mitterrand ou qui en 80 appareils un peu
comme cette figure de sauveur mais le
gros problème de
jean luc mélenchon par rapport à cette
image de sauveur c'est que c'est qu'au
c'est pas du tout en rassembleur
mélenchon quoi qu'il en dise aujourd'hui
à gauche il a été depuis cinq ans un
diviseur comme vous le disiez il a
beaucoup cassé du sucre sur le dos de
ses adversaires et puis lorsque yannick
jadot il ya quelques mois a voulu
attenter d'essayer de recoller un peu
les morceaux d'une gauche en débris il a
été l'un des premiers à refuser et
finalement la main tendue en tout cas à
refuser véritablement d'y aller parce
que ce qui compte pour lui c'est d'être
le premier à gauche depuis depuis dix
ans d'ailleurs là là je dis un fil
conducteur de sa de de son travail de
politique c'est patent d'arriver au
pouvoir que d'être le premier à gauche
que de se substituer au parti socialiste
et de faire de son de la france ssin
soumises ou de lâcheté de l'union
populaire
la première force à gauche donc on voit
bien que c'est et il n'a pas et ne peut
pas être cette figure de sauveur en tout
cas gaël sliman un point précis sur les
indécis puisque on est à trois semaines
c'est une des différences d'ailleurs
majeur avec avec l'appréhension elle dit
à 10 à 5 ans puisque son son grand
meeting of à cette grande marche avait
eu lieu à peu près au même moment au
printemps sauf que il avait plus de
temps pour progresser là on est à trois
semaines les indécis pèse encore lourd
dans dans vos études à une baisse très
très lourd mais je suis pas certain que
jean luc mélenchon ils puissent y puiser
beaucoup de réserve les indécis et les
personnes qui envisagent de s'abstenir
nous on est sur un indicateur
d'abstention qui est plutôt moins élevés
que ceux des confrères c'était déjà le
cas il ya cinq ans c'était plutôt révélé
d'ailleurs exact à l'époque ce tourne
autour d'une personne sur quatre dans
visage de s'abstenir mais on a plein de
gens qui nous disent qu'ils comptent
voter au premier ou au second tour mais
qui hésitent encore et qui sont très peu
certains de leurs choix 30 à 40 % des
gens qui comptent voter donc ça fait
beaucoup d'incertitudes si je peux
ajouter quand même quelque chose à ce
qui a été dit ou
complétez sur les chances de jean luc
mélenchon jean luc mélenchon de jouer ce
rôle de sauveur il ya une différence
énorme entre il ya cinq ans et
aujourd'hui c'est qu'entre temps jean
luc mélenchon s'est grillé si j'ose dire
auprès de très nombreux français avec
son fameux la république c'est moi et
avec des postures qui ont semblé -t
raisonnable pour ne pas pour effet ou
pour dire les choses de manières femise
et et il s'était déjà un petit peu
grillé au soir du du second tour de la
présidentielle par du premier tour plus
exactement en n'appelant pas clairement
à voter pour emmanuel macron c'est même
le moins qu'on puisse dire résultat dans
nos baromètres politiques ce que nous
réalisons ensemble avec vous thomas on a
à peu près une personne sur deux en
france qui dit ressentir de la
détestation à l'égard de jean luc
mélenchon c'est à un des recordmans
alors qu'eric zemmour qui est le
champion absolu du rejet mais jean-luc
mélenchon est aujourd'hui plus détestés
plus rejetée par les français que ne
l'est marine le pen par exemple donc ça
n'interdit pas d'espérer passer au
second tour par un quelconque miracle
dans la dernière intentions de vote aux
donc ça il ya un écart qui est encore
important entre marine le pen et lui
mais c'est vrai qu'il est en train de
déplacer des passes et valérie pécresse
et eric zemmour donc il y met dans une
dans un trend qui est positif mais même
si le passé au second tour les confrères
qui ont testé des hypothèse improbable
de second tour mélenchon marie ont des
résultats de type 2/3 1/3 donc la
possibilité qu'il puisse incarner un
espoir pour la gauche de se qualifier et
d'avoir une chance de gagner la
présidentielle est quasiment nul or
c'est l'un de ses arguments on va y
revenir du vote utile à gauche mathieu
vous êtes intéressé aux fins de campagne
ou de jean luc mélenchon lui fait ce
qu'on a parfois un sentiment de déjà vu
avec jean luc mélenchon alors normal me
direz-vous - c'est sa troisième campagne
oui mais à la différence d'autres
candidats qui ont fait trois campagnes
je pense à marine le pen par exemple
qu'elle fait une forme d' agent lamento
quand même sur sur son programme sur ce
qu'elle propose le leader a soumis lui
met un soin particulier à répéter les
mêmes figures d'habitude on ne change
pas une méthode qui gagne jean luc
mélenchon lui ne change pas une méthode
qui perd hier il était à paris pour un
rassemblement en plein air comme il ya
dix ans le 18 mars 2012 s'était investi
c'était pas un république mais il
vantait déjà la constituante et la
sixième république et il était sont les
organisateurs 120000 déjà cinq ans plus
tard jour pour jour ils étaient où il
faisait une marche à la bastille et la
république comme hier les organisateurs
disaient qu'ils étaient 130 me laisse
deviner quoi qu'est-ce qu'il vantait la
consultante et la 6ème république
exactement comme hier je présente et je
prends par exemple mais j'aurais pu
prendre marseille parce qu'il ya dix ans
c'était le prado cent vingt mille
personnes selon les organisateurs il ya
cinq ans c'était le vieux-port 70000 et
puis devinez quoi dimanche prochain ça
sera le prado donc l'homme pour lui une
certaine constance ira-t-on mais les
mêmes idées les mêmes rassemblement et
le même candidat peuvent-ils produire
autre chose qu'eux mêmes résultats non
même sont à cet instant t de l'ada de la
campagne une une progression régulière
et sandales oui alors j'allais dire
comme en 2012 et en 2017 reste à savoir
comment l'aventuré se terminera pour lui
cette fois ci car les fins de campagne
de jean luc mélenchon sont parfois
difficiles et souvent synonyme de coup
de fatigue alors en 2012 ça s'est très
mal terminé c'est le scénario du pétard
mouillé jean luc mélenchon commence
l'année autour de 7% dans les sondages
il grimpe il grimpe jusqu'à espérer
ravir la 3e place à marine le pen à la
mi mars il est à 10% début avril le
voile à 14% mi-avril un sondage le
crédite même de 10 7% en 2012 avril 2012
et puis le soir du premier tour baisse
et terminus tout le monde descend il est
à 11,1 pour cent cinq ans plus tard 2017
ça c'est le scénario du boulet de canon
début mars il a 10 % début avril il part
en avril par dunga pas 15% mi-avril et
s'installent autour de 18 et il finira
comme tout le monde le sait à 19,58 les
fameuses 600 mille voix des cas qui le
sépare du second tour comme il était et
alors cette fois ci cette fois ci les
quelque chose qui change quand même
j'entendais ce que les again simone
c'est quand même que le ticket de
qualification va baisser donc
mécaniquement ça lui laisse quand même
un peu plus de chance même s'il a peut
être de réserves de voix en tout cas
pour progresser pendant cette campagne
de premier tour et puis même ses
adversaires le reconnaissent jean luc
mélenchon sait y faire c'est un tribun
hors pair ce sans doute le meilleur
qu'on a dans cette campagne
présidentielle et selon un schéma
désormais bien connus comme en 2017 jean
luc mélenchon en arranger le bruit et la
fureur et là il a enfilé un nouveau
costume nos costumes de la tortue
s'agace qui trace son chemin et beaucoup
plus patelin c'est beaucoup plus
rassembleur parce que je pense qu'ils
les gars moins véhément il a choisi
cette tactique après c'est vrai avant je
une insoumission comme comme vous le
disiez tout à l'heure il a quand même
choisi l'idée que à gauche il est le
seul à pouvoir fédérer les espoirs
d'ailleurs il répond pas aux critiques
de la gauche
vous l'entendez plus cogné contre ses
rivaux de gauche ses concurrents mais il
concentre ses tirs sur le président
sortant avec une seule question quand
même ce qu'il n'est pas en train de se
tromper d'adversaire parce que emmanuel
macron c'est éventuellement le second
tour mais son adversaire le détour c'est
marina méridien justement qu'est ce que
vous en pensez est ce qu'ils se
rendaient en plus sur emmanuel macron
bien possible mais je juste pour revenir
on évoquait eric zemmour je trouve qu'il
ya quelque chose de parallèles entre les
figures d'eric zemmour et de jean luc
mélenchon tous les deux sont de bon
tribun bon jean luc mélenchon l'est
peut-être meilleure encore il aime la
culture l'histoire et les gens les
français les créditent de sa maison il
on se met alors à la différence d'eric
zemmour qui a finalement quand même une
proposition très qui fait système en
fait qui est vraiment elle tient sur
deux trois points donc c'est assez
facile de faire système dans ces cas là
jean luc mélenchon lui il s'est un peu
contredire parce que précisément il dit
qu'il est défenseur de la république et
puis après comme on l'a évoqué tout à
l'heure il dit la république c'est moi
en pleine perquisition donc là il ya une
petite contradiction il parle aussi de
la monarchie présidentielle est par
ailleurs en fait y vante est lui même si
son terme sont six à risme donc ses
contradictions là je pense ont contribué
aussi quand même au fil du temps à
affaiblir quand même la portée de son
message et j'ajouterais qu'il ya un
contexte plus général jean luc mélenchon
c'est la figure du populisme de gauche
en france c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il
se retrouve face au populisme de droite
marine le pen sur le plan européen les
populisme de gauche ils ont échoué il ya
podemos ça
effectivement ça finit dans la passe et
en grèce la même chose donc il était
porté en 2010 est quand même par cette
vague là qui n'existe plus aujourd'hui
donc je pense qu'il ya tout un ensemble
un contexte qui ne favorise pas alors on
parlait d'abstention maintenant puisque
vous l'avez les uns et les autres évoqué
rapidement et je vous propose d'entendre
l'appel en quelque sorte lancé par il
coquerel sur public sénat c'était ce
matin il y aura peut-être aussi une
partie aujourd'hui des personnes qu'ils
imaginent des électeurs qu'imagine voté
pour fabien roussel ou d'autres qui
finiront pas se dire bah ça vous calme
le coup d'avoir un duel entre monsieur
macro mélenchon sénat miser sur l'effet
28e sur un mode qu'on appelle à voter
efficace qu'on appelle expression parce
que le vote utile on en a été victime
pendant très longtemps qui était l'idée
de dire on va au mieux voter socialiste
même si vous n'êtes pas du tout d'accord
avec le ps nous ce qu'on veut c'est
votre cas sur notre programme voilà mais
encore une fois je vous assure je pense
que c'est d'abord les absences you
potentiel abstentionnistes qui font la
différence
stewart cholet l'électorat de jean luc
mélenchon c'est un électorat populaire
qui a plutôt tendance à se mobiliser
tardivement dans une campagne électorale
la maxime elle vaut toujours aujourd'hui
oui mais c'est vrai que c'est une
campagne qui est porté par un triptyque
émotionnelle qui est quand même
clairement défini depuis le début ses
ennuis indifférence et incompréhension
donc là on est dans le rêve de votre
livre à la dent le thème vous permettrez
de bien sûr mais parce que je pense que
c'est une une des clés d'explication
aussi de mobilisation ou de
démobilisation d'un certain nombre
d'électeurs sur l'électorat jean luc
mélenchon ce qui est intéressant c'est
quand vous dresser le profil émotionnel
c'est la résignation de la colère et du
désespoir le risque c'est que cette
colère abandonnées elles finissent aussi
par être résigné auquel cas finissent
par être tué finalement qu'elle
démobilise donc la question c'est est ce
que finalement jusqu'au bout cet
électorat populaire de gauche
effectivement saura mettre un bulletin
de vote quel qu'il soit et pour le coup
jean luc mélenchon ou est ce que
finalement elle vatin pas tomber dans
une forme de d'apathie aussi
démocratique parce qu'aujourd'hui elle
voit avec beaucoup de défiance aussi les
institutions politiques et leur
présentant ses excuses on trouve un peu
les mêmes émotions négatives dans
l'électorat de marine le pen alors ce
qui est intéressant c'est que chez
marine le pen on a à peu près
effectivement ce même à lot d'émotions
négatives par contre il ya un état
d'esprit beaucoup plus positif et
d'ailleurs c'est les différences aussi
entre marine le pen et eric zemmour
c'est à dire qu on a à peu près les
mêmes émotions pour autant l'état
d'esprit chez eric zemmour chez les
électeurs d'eric zemmour et plus dé
gatif alors que chez marine le pen est
plus positif maintenant on va voir ce
que ça veut ce que ce que tout cela
donne aussi dans les collisions gaël
sliman si on fait un gros plan un focus
sur sur cet enjeu de de l'abstention là
où là aussi on est beaucoup dans le dans
la bagarre entre marine le pen et jean
luc mélenchon il ils ont à peu près le
même défi à relever l'une et l'autre
est-ce que vous iriez ça
tout à fait ils vont avoir le même la
même difficulté au niveau social
sociologique 1 sur notre indicateur
d'abstention donc autour d'un quart des
français s'abstiendrait si l'élection
avait lieu dimanche prochain ce qui est
énorme séances à ses curés ce premier
tour de de 2022 au deuxième plus haut
niveau d'abstention à un premier tour
sous la vème république ce qu'on voit
c'est qu'il ya effectivement une
abstention très forte chez les jeunes on
est à 37 % deux jeunes de 25 à 34 ans
qui s'abstiendrait si l'élection avait
lieu dimanche prochain et une abstention
très forte chez les foyers les plus
modestes on est à 30 6% c'est en gros
des ratios du simple au double par
rapport à un électorat plus âgé ou un
aigle et un électorat plus aisés et ça
ça va grainé ou handicapées les chances
de marine le pen autant que celle de
jean luc mélenchon parce que il puise
il arrive à séduire pas mal c'est
électorat là mais la différence c'est
que l'électorat de marine le pen et nani
est un électorat plus motivés on est
environ 1 20 % des lecteurs habituels
rn2 gens qui se disent proches du r'n
qu'ils pourraient s'abstenir alors qu'on
est à 28 % chez les insoumis donc il ya
un risque est encore plus fort chez les
insoumis coco rassemblement national
mais c'est clair qu'il existe dans pour
les deux candidats on va continuer de
comparer en quelques sortes les
électorale jean luc mélenchon et de
marine le pen et pour ça je propose à
steve jourdain ii de nous rejoindre
bonsoir tinondia bienvenue roues on va
parler dans cette campagne de du leader
de la france insoumise d'une thématique
importante c'est la thématique du
pouvoir d'achat que propose-t-il la
retraite à 60 ans la retraite à 60 ans
c'est la mesure sur laquelle jean luc
mélenchon mise pour se distinguer des
manuels macron c'est plus largement la
mesure sur laquelle il mise pour séduire
l'électorat de gauche car selon lui eh
bien il ya d'un côté la droite dont fait
partie selon lui emmanuel macron et puis
il ya jean luc mélenchon écouter le hier
jamais
pour qu'il n'a pas une carrière complète
- de niro pour titre que ce soit choisi
ces tensions la retraite à 65 ans avec
maquereau ou la retraite à 60 ans avec
mélenchon oui ce qu'on entend avec
mélenchon les les électeurs potentiels
vendront voteront pour un vrai poème de
gauche mais c'est en tout cas le message
que jean luc mélenchon tente de faire
passer notamment aux déçus du idéalisme
et du jadot ismahan chez passion on dit
ça vraiment comme ça si vous votez
mélenchon vous aurez les choses
suivantes le smic net à 1400 euros et
tout de suite on m'a longtemps une
sixième semaine de congés payés et la
retraite donc à 60 ans voilà quelques
unes des propositions phare de jean luc
mélenchon il en faut une des
propositions phare dans une campagne
dans cette élection voit très peu de
propositions whaou de mesures vraiment
percutant teint qui marque les esprits
jean luc mélenchon veut faire de
l'augmentation du smic l'un de ses
marques écoutez le c'est l'union
populaire l'emportent il y aura le même
jour le décret sur l'augmentation du
smic à 1400 euros nets
le décret sur les blocages dépit le
pouvoir d'achat thème central donc jeu
de jean-luc mélenchon thème principal
aussi vous en parliez thomas de marine
le pen depuis six mois maintenant et
quand on regarde les sondages mais on se
rend compte qu environ un quart un quart
des électeurs potentiels de marine le
pen envisagerait de glisser un bulletin
mélenchon dans l'urne s'il venait et
bien se qualifier pour le deuxième tour
on comprend mieux la bataille qui se
joue actuellement entre les deux
candidats autour du pouvoir d'achat
merci steve à tout à l'heure pour notre
second débat effectivement c'est
intéressant jean garrigues où on avait
le sentiment que c'était plutôt les
propositions de marine le pen sur cette
thématique du pouvoir d'achat qui a
imprimé plus est ce que c'est en train
de changer d'une certaine façon oui j'ai
l'impression que le grand comme on
dirait que la grande vertu de jean luc
mélenchon dans cette campagne savoir
recentrer le débat sur cette question du
pouvoir d'achat il a été servi par les
événements puisque la guerre en ukraine
a recentré le débat là dessus on a bien
vu qu'il y avait toute une séquence
autour des thèmes de sécurité
d'immigration qui profitaient beaucoup à
eric zemmour qu'il avait d'ailleurs
lui-même installé dans le dans le débat
est là incontestablement le ce retour à
la question du pouvoir d'achat au social
est quelque chose qui manifestement et
est très utile en tout cas à jean luc
mélenchon mais le problème ont d'abord
c'est que au fond là on nous refait le
même coup qu'en 1981 et ceux qui ont un
peu de mémoire savent que les solutions
qui sont proposées aujourd'hui pas
forcément été des grands succès il ya
trente ans il ya 40 ans pardon bon mais
ça c'est cette une question et l'autre
problème c'est que la réponse à ces à
ces questionnements sociaux soul et et
sociétaux dire mais ce saut
essentiellement aujourd'hui c'est une
réponse populiste et que si vous
additionnez les voix de jean-luc
mélenchon et de marine
peut-être même une partie de l'électorat
d'eric zemmour vous avez une réponse
populiste qui commet des âges questionne
quand même par rapport à la faisabilité
et la viabilité de tout ça et sur le en
prenant un peu de recul sous les c c'est
quand même très inquiétant par rapport à
l'état de notre démocratie dont je parle
premier à le dire mais je pense à le
ressentir mais incontestablement ils
viennent combler un vide de propositions
venant des partis traditionnels ceux qui
ont été dégagés déjà en 2017 et
notamment venant de la gauche on va dire
la gauche sociale-démocrate et ça c'est
un vrai problème c'est c'est
effectivement une force pour jean luc
mélenchon mais à terme pour la gauche
française je suis pas sûr que ça soit
très positif moi je trouve que il y
vient tard jean dunand sociale il a mené
sa campagne
pendant l'automne en tout cas sur des
thématiques qu'on a davantage entendu de
sa bouche qui était la bifurcation et
écologique fase qu'ils nomment la
transition écologique qui est devenue
une bifurcation qui était aussi le cv
fameuse sixième république il fallait à
l'époque pour lui plus élevé la volaille
écologistes s'étaient plus le problème
c'est les socialistes parce qu'ils
étaient à ras de terre mais c'était de
la seule concurrence à gauche elle était
verte pour jean luc mélenchon al'inverse
je trouve que marine le pen assez vite
plus vite que jean luc mélenchon n'a
pris le virage du pouvoir d'achat dès la
fin de l'automne quand elle a compris
que la bataille sur l'immigration toute
façon devenait inaudible parce que eric
zemmour parler d'immigration parce que
la droite classique par l'immigration
parce que l élimination et parce que en
plus la thématique du pouvoir d'achat
monter parce que j aie
qu'elle va enfourcher ce cheval après
jean-luc mélenchon dans son discours
d'hier il y avait des accents beaucoup
plus sociaux va alors qu'il est toujours
porté dans son programme je dis pas qu
ils les inventent mais qui m'est témoin
avant la retraite à 60 ans c'est pour
lui évidemment une façon de se reposer
les méthodes macron mais c'est aussi un
message en subliminal aux électeurs
potentiels électeurs lepénistes même si
le vois pas comme ça parce que marine le
pen à renoncer à la retraite à 60 ans
c'était quand même un de ces totems et
début février elle a revu son projet et
le elle donne la retraite à 60 ans pour
les gens qu'on 42 annuités et qui ont
démarré le boulot à 20 ans aime un
spectre beaucoup plus restreint que sa
promesse qui était une vieille promesse
de 2012 et il a parlé aussi je trouve
beaucoup il est aux enseignants étaient
quelque chose qui était une clientèle
électorale entre guillemets très
socialiste et socialistes desmarais
toujours la campagne par l'éducation en
2012 c'était françois hollande et essai
recrutement de 60 professeurs en 2022
c'est anne hidalgo et je vais doubler le
salaire de tous les enseignants c'est un
très très grand classique à gauche mais
ce n'était pas tellement un classique de
la france insoumise et là hier il a
quand même adressé des messages assez
fort aux enseignants pour dire en gros
y'a que moi y'a que moi là dedans si je
en caricaturant le projet de mâcon en
disant il va faire des écoles
aujourd'hui des entreprises essaient de
mettre le libéralisme privées partout
dans l'éducation moi je suis garant je
suis le rempart à ces méthodes la
10e place c'est vrai qu'en fait il se
place là on attendait la gauche alors
dans un contexte qui est aussi favorable
aux thématiques de gauche c'était tout à
fait stupéfiant de ne pas entendre
davantage la gauche le pouvoir d'achat
c'est quand même vraiment si c'est le
mot d'ordre de cette famille là donc il
se place là dessus effectivement avec
moi je trouve qu'il a du retard par
rapport complètement d'accord je pense
que marine le pen a eu une intuition
quand même
vraiment donc qu'est donc si ce qui fait
que ça lui donne un avantage sur
l'abstention les jeunes il ya aussi
quelque chose que vous notiez dans un
précédent livre sur le fait qu'il ya une
droitisation quand même de cette
jeunesse et donc ça me semble donner
l'avantagé aux siens marine le pen c'est
à dire que j'ai été d'ailleurs très
intéressé par le fait que le terme enfin
la lutte contre le libéralisme
économique elle n'est pas du tout aussi
forte qu'on peut l'imaginer dans cette
fraction de la population donc là un
mélenchon bas et quand même tout à fait
en porte à faux par rapport à cette
tendance là donc c'est là aussi ça donne
un avantage à marine le pen est dernier
point a souligné par rapport à aux
écologistes
là il ya quelque chose qui
vraisemblablement l'a servi c'est le
départ de sandrine rousseau parce que du
coup en fait ils récupèrent les voix au
qualifié hâtivement de hawke dans les
médias mais c'est à dire que tous ces
thématiques de déco féminisme de gens
etc il peut les en fait récupéré tous
ces gens qui sont attachés à ces
thématiques qui était chez jadot parce
que rousseau et finalement et ben il
peut récupérer sa et nourrir un peu ces
troubles ça sera pas suffisant je pense
mais ça lui donne de quelques quelques
apports supplémentaires alors le
dynamisme à parce qu'il importe on l'a
vu avec les chiffres tout à l'heure qui
porte jean luc mélenchon et qui le
rapproche même si l'écart est encore
important de marine le pen salue vos
forcément quelques attaques de la
candidate du rassemblement national par
exemple ce matin sur france info toutes
les hypothèses sont possibles mais si
c'est le cas alors j'en appelle à aux
électeurs qui sont attachés à la france
parce que jean luc mélenchon je vous
rappelle ses soutiens quand même à des
théories racialistes des théories
des groupements islamistes
c'est
vraiment une politique de déconstruction
de notre pays donc tous ceux qui sont
des patriotes doivent regarder cette
situation et et voter en conscience
quand vous analysez cette attaque si
ward chaude de marine le pen est ce que
c'est un signe de fébrilité est ce que
finalement les dents sont dans dans
cette thématique classique
je pense que ce qui ce qui est bien joué
de la part de jean luc mélenchon sait
qu'il a imposées en l'espace de quelques
jours l'idée qu'un second tour macro
mélenchon est à la fois peut-être plus
désirable pour les français et 2 qui
était légitime et crédible donc
effectivement je pense qu'ils les notes
dans qui entoure marine le pen donc
parfaitement perçu pour autant je trouve
que ce qui est intéressant c'est la
question effectivement on en revient du
pouvoir d'achat sur quels sont les deux
candidats marine le pen avait quand même
plutôt bien géré son son début de
campagne je dirais d'octobre à janvier
où elle a laissé plutôt le terrain eric
zemmour avec une thématique
monothématique sur l'immigration elle
est venue très très vite au pouvoir
d'achat avec la crise qui a amplifié et
c'est sur un élément qui est quand même
sur déterminant dans le vote des
français 57% des français considèrent
que c'est les mesures qui sont à très
haut pouvoir d'achat qui détermineront
leur vote c'est très loin d'eux les
autres indicateurs 27% la guerre en
ukraine d'ailleurs qui est lié et puis
ensuite l'environnement qui a moins de
27 % vous voyez c'est la campagne
présidentielle du pouvoir d'achat
georges juste un petit élément de
d'analystes qui moi me surprend c'est
l'absence dans ce débat-là des corps
intermédiaires des syndicats sur la
présence effectivement de ce pouvoir de
vivre de la revalorisation du travail on
a quand même l'impression que le débat
est là mais pas toujours à les acteurs
les plus attendus alors sur sur la
question gaël sliman je reviens vers
vous de dudu du travail de l'emploi
votre baromètre de ce mois de mars est
intéressant parce qu il ressort que sur
ces thématiques qui sont assez
prioritaires a encore dans cette
campagne emmanuel macron bénéficie quand
même d'un capital confiance qui est
important oui effectivement c'est le
baromètre observateurs du travail qu'on
réalise pour morgane philips où on
balaye tout un tas de sujets qui sont en
lien avec le travail l'emploi la manière
dont travaille aujourd'hui les droits
des salariés et sur tous ces sujets là
quand on fait la liste des candidats
alors aucun ne trouve grâce à prix d'une
majorité auprès de plus d'une majorité
de français mais ont rejoint ce que vous
disiez les uns et les autres jean luc
mélenchon a pris beaucoup de retard on
investir le thème du pouvoir d'achat
notamment il du travail en général parce
que là dessus emmanuel macron est très
largement devant les autres à 43% marine
le pen ne recueille que 37% de jugement
positif sur ce qu'elle ferait si elle
était au pouvoir dans le domaine de
l'emploi et du travail en france valérie
pécresse est à 36 jean luc mélenchon et
décroché à 29 pas très loin d'eric
zemmour et pour quelqu'un qui est le
dernier représentant finalement de la
gauche encore en situation de pouvoir
espérer se qualifier au second tour il
aurait pu et dû faire bien mieux
s'il ne s'était pas abîmer comme il l'a
fait depuis le début du quinquennat
d'emmanuel macro et même avant cela
depuis l'entre-deux tours il serait
aujourd'hui dans une position bien plus
favorable s'il avait aussi investi cette
thématique du pouvoir d'achat plus tôt
c'est un petit peu du gâchis pour la
gauche parce que je rappelle que la
gauche ça existe en france par les
électeurs de gauche ça existe il avait
encore un président aux poudres ar il ya
cinq ans ils n'ont pas disparu
mécaniquement ils ne veulent pas voter
hidalgo elle est à des niveaux de score
extrêmement faible ils n'ont pas été
enthousiasmé par jadot et il le reste
mélenchon mais ils ont de grosses
réserves par rapport à ce candidat là
pour les raisons que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure et puis effectivement parce
qu'il a investi beaucoup trop tard cette
thématique les du travail de l'emploi et
du pouvoir d'achat sur laquelle il avait
toutes les cartes en main a priori
pouvoir d'achat prix des carburants
évidemment c'était le point de départ du
mouvement d'aidé gilet jaune mathieu il
ya eu 1 c'est plus qu'un clin d'oeil
quoi il ya eu 1 voilà un message appuyé
vers les mobiles et jaune avec cette
sorte d' amnistie ce qui montre bien
qu'on est dans un populisme de gauche
tels que jean luc mélenchon fait feu de
tous les abstentionnistes ce sont ces
réserves de voix c'est vrai qu'il peut
pas aller piocher ailleurs parce que
ailleurs n'existe pas le ps est à 2% il
ya yannick jadot et horaires à ce qu'ils
le score qui fait mais c'était très très
faibles réserves quand on prend le total
gauche s'est on posé au médecin dans
tous les sens j'ai à ça ne permet pas de
figurer au second tour de belle manière
donc il faut aller chercher d'autres
gens et donc dans les abstentionnistes
et quand même des clins d'oeil plus
qu'appuyé à des franges qui ont été dans
la radicalité que ce soit les gilet
jaune dont il veut amnistier les gêner
les gens qui ont été condamnés enfin il
leur promet une amnistie totale à
l'autre qui m'a choqué c'est le clin de
fûts aux antilles vax soignants dans les
soignants qui avait refusé de se faire
soigner et qui lui pour le coup avait
été sorti de l'hôpital on se souvient
alors qu'ils avaient créé la polémique
jean luc mélenchon leur dis venez avec
moi je voudrais intègre à l'hôpital donc
et quand même on est là on est vraiment
peut-être le veut il se veut le
réceptacle de la colère dont par les
stewards tout à l'air de tout les clairs
parce qu'il a échoué une chose juste et
je termine là dessus il faut se souvenir
de qui était jean luc mélenchon en
septembre 2010 est il est élu député ce
qui n'était pas le cas en 2012 il
s'était fait bananer vous souvenez
hénin beaumont donc là il est du député
il est à la tête d'un gros bénéfices et
il a tout ce qu'il faut pour être le
premier opposant aymane vaincrons parce
que la droite est éparpillé façon puzzle
et que le ps n'existe plus et il engage
un rapport de force avec emmanuel macron
dès l'automne 2010 est en disant moi je
vais mettre un million de personnes dans
la rue pour casser les ordonnances sur
la l'autre enfin vous souvenez les la
réforme de du travail de de muriel
pénicaud à l'époque et il échoue parce
qu'il est ici il fait pas le lien avec
les syndicats ils se disent forme ça
tout seul et puis après c'est une autre
dégringolade mais ils avaient cette
posture la de réceptacle de toutes les
colères et ils l'aï laissée à mon avis
de la retrouver pour commencer et
justement il avait effectivement capter
cette colère en 2017 mais le mouvement
des gilet jaune est intéressant parce
qu'on voit que cette colère ils
n'arrivent pas lui à la canaliser jafari
avait personne n'a réussi personnes face
à ce moment léger jouit
capitale de la thuringe à dire c'était
ça son son son moteur c'était
précisément cette colère sociale donc
d'où problème quand même pour
aujourd'hui que mélenchon est donc le
mouvement est parti effectivement dans
des dents dans des directions dans une
impulsion propres il n'a pas pu
capitaliser là dessus et ce qu'il a fait
simplement c'est de dire de célébrer
eric briquet quand même le monsieur qui
a dit rentrons on va rentrer à l'elysée
donc là je reviens sur j'ai tout à
l'heure pour un défenseur de la
république là aussi ça fait quand même
un peu tâche donc il ya encore des
contradictions d impuissance qui se sont
accumulés jusqu'à aujourd'hui jean marie
voulait pendre le 6 sur ce thème oui
parce qu'ils étaient apparus en 2010 est
que comme comme jaurès le tenant d'une
république humaniste et sociale qui
s'opposaient à la république start-up
demel macro mais il est il est passé par
la case reid roux est justement et ça ça
l'à beaucoup brouillé son image ils
essaient de re re devenir de redevenir
jaurès mais on voit bien que que ça ne
fonctionne pas et plus grave encore je
le répète et il est à mes yeux le
fossoyeur de la gauche française d'une
gauche qui existe ailleurs en allemagne
en italie en espagne d'une gauche qui
n'est pas la sienne qui est une autre
gauche celle qui était inconsolable
comme l'a dit avec raison d'ailleurs
manuel valls mais cette gauche existe et
elle est écrasée par va par là le la
lame la direction populiste qui a été
prise par par jean luc mélenchon est
donc pour lui il sera très certainement
satisfait d'avoir fait peut-être le même
coup que qu'en 2010 c'est d'arriver très
très proche peut-être dû secondes pour
peut-être même d'y être mais je le
répète à court terme dans l'histoire de
la gauche française je vois qu'il aura
rendu un assez mauvais service les
candidats de la gauche social-démocrate
l'attaquent évidemment même angle
d'attaqué pour anne hidalgo et pour
yannick jadot europe ecologie les verts
les prises de position passées de jean
luc mélenchon sur poutine et la russie
nos positions sur le conflit craignant
nos positions historiques sur vladimir
poutine s'est quand même jean luc
mélenchon qui disait que vladimir
poutine est réglé le problème syrien
quand il bombarder des populations
civiles qui considérait que l'ukraine
faisait partie finalement de la russie
c'est ce qu'ils disaient soit on est
pour les démocraties soit pour les
dictatures il n'y a pas une troisième
voie d'un aligné avec la complaisance
dont
mélenchon jean luc mélenchon a fait
preuve vis-à-vis de vladimir poutine
dont il a fait preuve aussi parce qu'on
peut prendre tout le sujet
internationale vis-à-vis de maduro au
venezuela ou encore de bachar al assad
en syrie stewart show pour pourquoi on a
peut-être que je me trompe mais jean-luc
mélenchon souffre quand même un peu
moins par exemple qu'un eric zemmour de
ses prises de position passées vis-à-vis
du duo régime
l'annuaire poutine alors c'est vrai que
minsk est intéressant c'est qu'il pâtit
un peu moins me par rapport à user moore
de cette guerre de crem ses prises de
position moi je pense que déjà le
déterminant du sujet de la relation
internationale ou même de ses positions
sur son électorat est plutôt faible même
pour marine le pen c'est la différence
entre le pen et et zemmour c'est
reconnaît un électorat zemmour qui est
quand même en majorité plus diplômées
donc et peut-être aussi plus sensibles à
ces questions là et dans le voc est
peut-être plus déterminée sur ces
aspects là pour barry nos peines et les
peut-être un peu moins le cas et je
pense que pour jean luc mélenchon cessé
de dans la même façon je reviens juste
si vous permettez sur la question de la
colère qu'il n'arrive pas à capitaliser
je pense que il n'arrive pas à
capitaliser comme l'ensemble aujourd'hui
du personnel politique parce que il
pâtit aussi aujourd'hui d'une défiance
politique qui est évidente de la part de
l'opinion publique qui considère que ça
ne sera pas par la voie politique
procéderont les réponses aux enjeux qui
les concernent dont le pouvoir d'achat
d'ailleurs chez les jeunes on le voit
bien ce qui a été le plus formellement
dit c'est qu'il n'y a pas de traduction
politique possible et lorsqu'il y en a
eu ça n'a pas fonctionné donc la colère
qui ne se concrétisent pas forcément
pour un candidat c'est aussi à mon sens
une alerte de la défiance envers le
personnel politique merci la colère qui
est l'une des émotions évidemment que
vous êtes à votre livre l'opinion des
émotions qui est publié aux éditions de
l'aube et à la fondation jean jaurès
merci merci à tous rappelle également
jean le titre de votre livre la
tentation du sauveur c'est aux éditions
payot merci encore d'avoir participé à
ce à ce débat